ramadan ist luca meine lieben freunde
ich mache heute endlich mal wieder mit
seiner eine würdest du air challenge
ich freue mich richtig und du gar nicht
sandra würdest du er in einem schloss
leben wollen oder eine yacht besitzen
wollen in dem schloss leben wollen lässt
die queen java omg wie wohnt ja nicht in
einem schloss übrigens meine oma grad in
leuchtender queen geknüpft
die queen ist aus dem ministerium die
liebt gefühlt seit 4000 jahren
ich würde eher eine yacht haben wollen
ich glaube wir werden damit auch in der
überzahl sind in der unterzahl ja
lacht folter immer ripped ja aber mir
ist dann schluss zu groß diese ganze
räume was willst du damit auch in
amerika wenn die soeben
immobilienvorstand sie haben hier 70
badezimmer dk ich habe nicht mal drei
freunde nicht mehr ein
außerdem würdest du lieber gezwungen
sein 24 stunden am stück meine deponie
zu gucken oder den intro song für dein
leben lang im kopf als ohrwurm zu haben
sie war 24 stunden mein pony cook will
ich auch machen sind wir auch mit 88
nach vorne
würdest du er die letzten momente deines
lebens mit seiner familie verbringen
oder etwas verrücktes machen was du dich
noch nie getraut hast also was wie und
fallschirmsprung oder irgendwie so
meiner familie ich glaube ich würde auch
die familie nehmen und damit sind wir
ganz knapp nur in der mehrheit krass
wirst du die letzten minuten des teams
mit mir verbringen wollen planen hättest
du lieber einen extrem großen kopf aber
dafür einen ganz kleinen nacken oder
einen ganz langen nacken und ganz
kleinen kopf du hast du was ich bin das
ja eigentlich nur dass die großen kopf
ich habe großen kopf du hast mein kopf
aber der bulgare
also was nicht mehr als zwei grad den
großen korb ok nämlich auch
dass ich mit 60 prozent was soll sich da
was geht so kassner
herzlich würdest du lieber die ganze
zeit leben oder gar nicht leben
dann über die ganze zeit oder
aber ich wusste das es irgendwann
scheiße wird wenn du die ganze zeit
lebten ja das hatten wir glaube ich
schon mal irgendwann sind deine ganzen
freunde halt droht die sache ist ja dass
auf aber
dann
nimmst du dir nie was vor weil du weißt
du kannst es für immer machen na ja
schon mal vor man sagt sich sonst ja
lass mal
bahamas fliegen nun mache ich und 300
jahren ja okay also neben auf jeden fall
aber lieber weil es immer noch besser
als gar nicht zu leben würde ich sagen
klar in der mehrheit die nächste frage
meine lieben freunde sleep in your
parents bett also würdest du lieber in
dem bett seiner eltern jede dach
schlafen oder jedes mal was
würdest du dich lieber teleportieren
können oder in der zeit reisen also
beides hat ja mit dem ortswechsel zu tun
entweder du sagst ich will jetzt direkt
von hier in barcelona seinen zwei
sekunden oder du was sagst ich rede
ja
nicht heim travel
safe ich würde so gerne so ein paar
sachen ungeschehen machen schon mal vor
du beispielsweise im straßenraum fall
und so und denkt sie dann einfach nur
verdammt hätte ich mal einfach irgendwie
das auto da gesehen dass ich rein
gefahren wäre dann hätte kannst du kurz
fünf sekunden zurück sprung macht es
richtig
moralapostel würdest du lieber gegen
einen alligator also gegen ein
gefährliches krokodil rasseln oder gegen
einen bären klappt alle guard war
nämlich einen bären ich könnt' ich würde
meine hand dafür verwenden dass wir in
überzahl dies wären alligator einfach
zickzack laufen weil da kunden nicht so
schnell hinterher rissen sneakers erst
du lieber extrem witzig oder komplett
schön ich glaube wir können seine
zwischen dafür weiter extrem schön sind
aber dann nehmen wir das tiroler ich bin
extrem wohl lustig ich bin extrem schön
ne yo ist beides nicht
du willst du du wärst total gern lustig
aber ich bin also was nehmen wir
gar nichts ich habe beides
ok überspringen die frage nächste frage
never play computergames kann also nie
computerspiele
zola prozent sondern spielt die ganze
zeit dura du ja aber das ist ja auch ein
computerspiel
wir nehmen dann glaube ich trotzdem dass
man nie wieder computerspiele spielt
sind damit auch in der mehrheit deswegen
nächste frage listen to die macarena pro
4 die also vier stunden lang macarena
lied hören oder mambo number five für
fünf stunden
[Musik]
ebenfalls auf vier stunden was ist mambo
number zweifel
haben es geschafft
würdest du lieber an dem ganzen leben
nie wieder schuhe tragen oder nie wieder
ein auto fahren du machst beides nicht
ja sander trägt weder schule noch fährt
sie auto
muss beantworten die frage ist ob das
heißt dass man selber kein auto mehr
fahren darf oder ob man auch nicht bei
anderen leuten
dieses spiel genau wusste dass ein
porsche fahrer bist aber ich weiß genau
dass ferrari die mehrheit sein wie ihr
porsche ist das bessere auto muss man so
sagen jeder der ahnung von autos
halbiert das sagen würdest du dir die
ganze welt in roten farben sehen oder
fast nichts hören können wenn leute zu
dir sprechen ich würde alles in rot
sehen wollen ich würde einfach ein
hörgerät kaufen und das nehmen
du hast immer recht irgendwie wärst du
lieber ohne vater oder eine mutter
aufgewachsen ohne vater ich glaube ich
würde auch mal das ist eine ganz
schwierige frage aber ich glaube ich
würde auch ohne
vater nehmen ich glaube nur mutter ist
nochmal so mehr die kritiker auch als
kind hat noch mal eine andere verbindung
irgendwie zu dir ja ok kraft sind gar
nicht gedacht wärst du lieber im wald
nacht alleine verloren oder in einem
verwunschenen
verfluchten haus
das hatten wir doch schon mal weiß ich
gar nicht
jetzt haben wir uns gestellt da haben
wir uns gestellt ich würde auf jeden
fall die wahrheit sein du hast gesagt in
einem haus ja weil jedoch stimmt da habe
ich wieder kam ich an wenn es regnet und
so dann hast du im wald bis zu folgen
und kalt und so weiter und in einem haus
ist man dann so zumindest ein bisschen
war apropos podcast leute ihr könnt sie
euch gerne anhören wo gibt es im pop
kamera
[Musik]
ich würde das verdienste haus nehmen auf
jeden fall ich bin die ganze zeit in der
unterzahl mit meinen antworten dabei
will opfer bis wir auf einer einsamen
insel gestrandet werden wird zu lieber
versuchen zu fliehen mit einem boot was
du dir dann baust oder würdest du lieber
da bleiben und hoffen dass du gefunden
wirst
ja glaube ich auch auf dem offenen
wasser wo willst du hin
was
mit dem boot bruder du kommst sich
weiter nehmen uns alle hobby würdest du
er komplett oder dein handy leben wollen
oder ohne deinen computer ipod und
frische klamotten okay also computer und
ipod brauche jetzt unbedingt brauchen
einhändig kommt auch videos theoretisch
hätten die schreiben weil mit dem man
sagt gar nichts von ihrer frische
klamotten ja ich glaub ich entscheide
mich leider verroht ich glaube ich nehme
auch
rot-weiß spielen das für menschen ich
glaube dass wir wollen eher ein handy
als frische klamotten ihr leben lang
meine frage
spielen das zehnjährige
hier an der stelle würden sei noch nicht
das heute geht allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn euch mal
wieder diese was würdest du er tun
machen seine niedrigen als kanal website
gefallen hat dingsbums jordan lassen
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
abonnieren ein kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn die weitere videos nicht
verpassen wollte sandra hat die letzten
sechs worte ich gehe jetzt nach hause